Let's consider the motion of
a car on a circular track,
and the track is frictionless.
And it's also banked.
So this is the overhead
view of our circular track.
It has radius, r.
And here's our car moving
at a constant velocity.
Now, from the side view when
we want to look at that bank
turn-- let's draw a side view.
So here's our side view, and the
car is moving with a velocity
into the plane of the figure.
Now this surface
here is frictionless.
And what we'd like
to do is find out
what speed the car can move
such that it doesn't slide
up or down the inclined plane.
So how should we analyze that?
Well our approach will be to
apply Newton's second laws.
Now what's very
important to realize
is this is circular motion.
And for circular motion
we know that the car
is accelerating towards
the center of the circle.
Now from the side view, towards
the center of the circle
is in this direction.
So the car is accelerating
radially inward.
And that will guide how we
choose our coordinate system.
And so we can then write
our free body force diagram.
So let's begin
with the analysis.
So we don't need to see
the overhead view anymore.
So I'll just remove that, and
then we can start drawing.
This is what we can refer to
as our acceleration diagram.
And now let's draw
the force diagram
on the car as our
choice of system.
So here's our angle, phi.
Because the
acceleration was inward
we're going to choose a
radially outward coordinate
and a vertical
coordinate, K hat up.
Notice that this is
different than just a mass
on a fixed incline
plane where we used unit
vectors up and down
the inclined plane.
The reason we choose
our unit vectors
like that-- to
emphasize it again,
is we already know this
is constrain motion.
It's circular motion.
Now what is the free body--
what are the forces on the car?
Well there is the normal
force, the plane on the car,
and the gravitational force.
Now here-- whenever you're
doing problems like this
remember that the
trig is crucial to get
these angles right.
So that's phi, and that's phi,
and that's our free body force
diagrams.
And now we can write
down Newton's second law.
So we'll start out with
our usual approach,
and we have two directions
that we have to consider.
So in the radial direction
there is an inward component
of the normal force, like that.
And that's opposite the
angle, so it's pointing
opposite our direction.
So we have minus n sine phi.
The gravitational force is
only in the negative K hat
direction.
And we know that the
acceleration is inward,
and so there's a minus sign.
We have the mass, and the
constraint for circular motion
is that that's phi
squared over r.
Where r was the
radius of that circle,
this can be thought of
as the central point.
Now for the k hat
direction, we have
a component of the normal
force that's pointing up.
I'll just draw that.
That's adjacent to the angle,
so we have plus and cosine phi.
And we have the gravitational
force downward, minus mg.
And as far as the
vertical direction
goes, because the car
is going in a circle,
there is no acceleration up or
down in the vertical direction.
Again, that's a constraint
in this problem.
That's equal to 0.
So in this problem, this
is the side that we know,
and we're trying to figure
out up to the speed, v. Now,
how do we analyze this problem?
Well you can see that if
I write my two equations,
this n sine phi equals
mv squared over r.
And cosine phi equals mg.
We have two equations.
We have two unknowns, v and n.
Many times people
just solve for n
and try to find the equation--
and then substitute in,
but you're also allowed
to divide two equations,
and that's much easier.
The masses cancel and we get the
relationship, that tan phi is v
squared over rg.
And so we have our result that
the speed that the car can
travel on a frictionless
inclined plane
and maintain uniform
circular motion
is exactly the square
root of rg tan phi.
And that's how we
analyze the motion
of this car on a banked turn.
What we would now
like to think about
is what would happen if
you're traveling faster
or slower than this speed.
So suppose we have the
prime bigger than the speed.
Now, what that means is
that the car is going faster
and the new equilibrium-- if you
asked what would the radius be
such that traveling
at v primed the car
undergoes circular
motion, the prime
would be equal to
r prime g tan phi.
And so in order to
go with this speed
you have to go at
a greater radius.
Now what does that mean?
Well, that means that if
the car is traveling at v,
so it's in this circular motion,
and now the driver increases
the speed to v
prime, the car will
start to slide up the
inclined plane-- remember,
it's frictionless--
until it reaches
a-- as it starts slide
up the inclined plane
it will get to this
new radius, r prime,
but because a car will have
a little inertia it will
overshoot that
speed, that radius,
and then it will start to come
back down the inclined plane,
and it will oscillate
about that point.
It won't be sinusoidal
oscillations,
but they'll be a
periodic oscillation
about this new radius, r prime.
The same thing, too, if we have
the double prime less than d,
then the double prime is equal
to r double prime G tan phi.
Now remember, this double
prime is not two derivatives.
I'm just using
that as a notation
to indicate different speeds.
So if the car is going
along at speed, v, and slows
down, what would happen
is the new equilibrium
radius is smaller so the car
slides down the inclined plane
until it gets to r double prime.
It turns out that it will
overshoot that a little bit,
and then start to move up.
And, again, it will oscillate
around this new equilibrium
length.
So on a frictionless
inclined plane
if you go faster then this
speed the car slides up.
If you go slower than this
speed, the car slides down.